quand la fédération des producteurs de
lait du québec finance une étude qui se
demandent comment désigner les cages des
poules pondeuses sans prononcer le mot
cage c'est signe qu'il ya un malaise
faut dire que de plus en plus de voix
s'élèvent pour décrier le sort de ces
volatiles entassés les uns sur les
autres c'est les choses progressent au
canada le pays est encore loin derrière
l'europe en matière de bien-être des
poules pondeuses
des élevages de poules pondeuses
entassées les unes sur les autres à cinq
ou six marquage sur plusieurs niveaux
[Musique]
quand les journalistes et le public ont
découvert ces cages conventionnelles
dans de larges bâtiment sans fenêtre ça
a été un choc en deux soirs à chaud
en élevage intensif les cages
conventionnelles sont l'une des plus
cruelles façon d'élever des animaux
l'industrie dans les pays européens on
conteste depuis des années cette façon
d'élever les poules pondeuses
la controverse est née quand les
consommateurs et les organisations de
défense des droits des animaux ont
estimé que l'industrie est allé trop
loin industry for being la seconde tout
fort au canada 56 5 % des éleveurs
utilisent encore ses cages dites
conventionnelles mais personne n'a voulu
nous les montrer nous vous présentons
donc des images captées au pays par nos
équipes au fil des ans
dans ses cages l'épaule disposent
chacune d'un espace de vie de quatre
cent trente deux centimètres carrés
moins que la superficie d'une feuille de
papier standard elles n'ont pas venu
pour pondre leurs oeufs par espace pour
déployer leurs ailes et font souvent de
l'ostéoporose fonds d'exercice
la densité est si élevé que le stress
provoque parfois du piquage de plume une
poule en pick up une autre jusqu'à ce
que la peau la victime soit mise à nu un
comportement qui peut aller jusqu au
cannibalisme
la première étape serait de les sortir
des cages et de leur permettre
d'exprimer leur comportement naturel
comme prendre une poussière picorer
gratter le sol en squat se percher avoir
accès à une y avait quatre as tu en as
boxe au canada certains éleveurs ont
pris ce virage comme charles éric
bouchard un éleveur de saint gédéon de
beauce son entreprise familiale a
répondu à l'appel d'une multinationale
qui voulait acheter des oeufs de poules
élevées sans cage en 2015 elsa fait
voulait fabriquer sa mère avec des deux
points qui est appelé en liberté en une
opportunité d'avoir une volière d'être
parmi les premiers au québec à commencer
à travailler avec ce système là me
décider de relever le défi
des oiseaux dans une volière ont accès
au sol donc elles vont pouvoir sauter
par terre pour pouvoir se promener au
courant de la journée un environnement
plus vastes
comme on peut le voir liberté n'est pas
synonyme d'accès aux pâturages je pense
que le mot liberté est un mot qui porte
à confusion c'est important de
comprendre que peu importe le type de
système commence lisent votre oeil à
bord une façon de contenir les animaux
pour peu que ces chats le bien-être
toujours être respectée mais à
l'intérieur d'un certain âge dans les
volières les poules au déni et des
perchoirs chaque animal dispose de 929
centimètre carré une fois et demie la
grandeur d'une feuille de papier
standard ça leur laisse suffisamment
l'espace pour prendre un bain de
poussière un comportement qu'elle adopte
dans la nature pour nettoyer leurs
plumes mais pour l'éleveur ce type de
système est loin d'être idéale de fait
les animaux vont pouvoir aller au sol
ils vont travailler sur une litière qui
est principalement fait de leurs propres
clients qui sont séchées il va y avoir
plus de bactéries qui vont se développer
finalement des maladies peut découler de
la mortalité est donc chez nous on
dénote beaucoup plus de mortalité dans
les volières
on va aller les voir c'est une façon
d'élever les oiseaux qui est différente
quand on décide d'aller vers les
logements alternatifs une adaptation qui
est à faire martin boulianne de
l'université de montréal étudie les
logements alternatifs pour le compte des
producteurs de lait du québec elle
constate que si la liberté a ses
avantages pour l'animal elle a aussi des
inconvénients
dans les grands groupes de poules la
hiérarchie s'installe de façon plus
agressive et le piquage de plume peut
être sévère sans compter les accidents
qui peuvent survenir dans un premier
temps ce qui était observé surtout en
europe c'est que vous avez un oiseau en
volière et qui est en liberté donc qui
dit liberté sur plusieurs étages j'ai
aussi que trauma parce qu'ils avaient
des oiseaux qui peuvent avoir des
problèmes à l'atterrissage on voit aussi
plus de parasitisme externe dae météo
pour l'instant ce sont surtout les
bactéries en suspension dans l'air des
volières qui pose problème il y à un
risque de maladie a cru mais il est tout
de même bien contrôlé dans les élevages
étudiée par la chercheuse
charles éric bouchard lui préfère un
autre système que les volières des cages
dites enrichi qui l'utilisent dans une
autre partie de la ferme et qui sont
plus grandes que les cages
conventionnelles
ici les poules disposent chacune de sept
cent cinquante centimètres carrés un
espace un peu plus grand qu'une feuille
de papier standard
je voudrais rester m'enrichissent ont
très bien fait dans le sens où ils
permettent d'offrir un environnement qui
est très salubre aux animaux donc libre
de fientes il va être capable d'exprimer
leur comportement naturel les oiseaux
vont chercher attendent dans les nids
donc la plupart du temps elles vont tous
derrière les rideaux rouges
alors là des perchoirs aussi à la
longueur du logement puis à des
territoires au canada 27 % des éleveurs
de poules pondeuses utilise ses cages
mais si l'on se fie à ces images captées
par nos équipes dans des élevages de
cages enrichi au pays tout ne se passe
pas toujours comme sur des roulettes à
preuve ses poules sévèrement des plumes
et leurs séjours dans ses habitacles ne
semble pas synonyme de bien-être
un effort a été fait avec les cages
enrichi les poules sont un petit peu
plus de place mais sont encore confiné
car leurs mouvements sont restreints
elles ne peuvent pas battre des ailes ni
courir et on a peine la place pour
marcher le problème c'est la cage
elle-même
[Musique]
certains consommateurs semblent penser
la même chose en 2016 les producteurs 2
du québec ont financé les recherches de
cet agroéconomiste qui voulait savoir ce
que les acheteurs québécois pensait du
concept de captivité le mot cage ses
goûts très très fort donc on a
questionné un pic année du dut et on
leur donnait 12 noms de logements de
poules dont trois qui avait le mot cage
à l'intérieur et sans aucune autre
information et on aurait tout simplement
dit classe est ce que vous croyez qu'il
logement de poule qui est le plus
intéressant en termes de bien-être
animal pour la poule et bien entendu les
trois qui avait le mot cage sans aucune
autre description étaient les plus bas
si bien que par la suite dans notre
édition ne pas utiliser le mot cage on
va utiliser le mot comme
logement confort ou encore
on avait les coups etc au confort ou des
trucs comme ça
depuis la fédération des producteurs 2
du québec évite systématiquement de
prononcer le mot cage
elle parle de logement
quoi qu'il en soit avec une majorité de
poules pondeuses toujours en cages
aménagées ou conventionnelle le canada
est loin derrière l'europe là bas les
cages conventionnelles ont été
interdites en 2012 ici l'industrie a
demandé à ses membres d'emboîter le pas
d'ici 2036 un sursis que défend charles
éric bouchard bien qu'il ne possède plus
ce genre de cage est ce que c'est normal
qu'on donne près de 25 ans une industrie
pour se tourner de bord alors que en
europe où on fait ce très rapidement je
pense que c'est tout à fait normal
considéra que pour la plupart des
producteurs sa demande de très gros
investissements de faire un nouveau bras
de fer
quelqu'un qui s'est construit en 2014
bâtisse neuve au sommet de la
technologie qui devrait mettre la clé à
la porte du jour au lendemain
je suis tout à fait raisonnable de
laisser vincent printemps producteurs
pour avoir le temps de changer de
système
[Musique]